[Music]
everyone welcome to simulation we have a
very special guest today we are going to
be talking about the cosmic perspective
we have Jill tarter hello Ellen thank
you for coming on to our show my
pleasure
greatly appreciate it and what a
tremendously important subject and I
think it's like you've called it the
gateway drug for science and for just
carrying a lot about the small pale blue
dot and sustainably progressing moving
forward in the future so you've been how
long have you been attracted to
astrophysics and and space in general
and the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence so how long what was your
like aha moment because for so many kids
we were talking about this when we were
sitting down this last week and there's
all these aha moments kids get to see
Saturn's rings through telescopes all
this different kind of stuff so what was
your aha moment that got you in and then
and then like tell us a bit about the
journey that led you to being the
director for the research at SETI as
well well have an undergraduate degree
in engineering so I got a really good
education in problem-solving but at the
end of that time I realized that the
problems that my engineering colleagues
were working on were not the ones that
were particularly interesting to me so I
had the luxury of staying around in
graduate school and taking a bunch of
different courses and I took a course
from Edwin saltpeter at Cornell on star
formation
you know stars have a life cycle they
get born and they live they die in
different ways and I thought AHA these
are interesting problems and so I
switched my my majored astrophysics and
got a PhD in astronomy and astrophysics
so that was that was my eye-opener my
key moment and so okay see you you were
like okay
stars have a lifecycle they're so
fascinating to see the star dust and
then the stars live and
the star is supernova and not all the
time now but and then die and then and
then the slow kind of build up over time
of understanding more and more about
space and all of its different vast
interests and so ok so what was the what
was the thesis in at the time I did a
thesis that had many parts it was huge
it talked about galaxies within clusters
spiral galaxies as they move through
clusters which are not devoid of
material there's actually background gas
and dust via the gas within the galaxies
gets stripped out by something we call
Ram pressure stripping and then I also
worried about tiny little stars that
form and collapse and try to fuse
hydrogen to helium at their cores but
they don't have enough mass to ever get
hot enough at the core for that fusion
to become sustained and so they
eventually just died out and our dark
and we wondered whether back in the day
when we were beginning to understand
that there was mass that we couldn't
account for we used to call it the
missing mass problem we wondered if
these little stars could be responsible
and I spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what they would look like but
I could never numerically paste an
atmosphere onto my model for the central
star and get a reliable prediction of a
color temperature which would have told
astronomers how to look at what
wavelength to look so I called them
brown brown dwarfs because according to
Edmund land Brown is not a color so I
wasn't be misleading anyone and it took
25 years to actually find the first lawn
and now they're a very favourites topic
of study and they're exotic and and very
numerous actually
I can't quite get over how important it
is that our show is called simulation in
many reasons because we strive to expand
people's awareness to the potential of
the vastness of the cosmic perspective
and what could have evolved on other
stars and what life would be like there
and all that interesting stuff as well
as the idea of once you gain enough
power of going into these virtual worlds
you know when how are we not just in one
right now and so when it comes to
talking about star systems I mentioned
this you know statistic to you as well
that one third of all star systems are
binary or multiple star systems which is
so unique and interesting to think about
that now one out of every star has at
least one planet orbiting technically
speaking yes and that's also
mind-blowing one out of every five has a
planet in the habitable zone orbiting it
where the conditions for evolving life
evolving are you know just right might
be might be just right and there is
they're just you know then the
instruments are becoming better and
better you've seen a tremendous amount
of change over your career now in terms
of the instruments and this includes
both things like Arecibo for SETI the
Allen telescope array but also things
like the Kepler telescope for for
exoplanet hunting so so yet so tell us
about tell us so I know we have some
really good slides to show as well so
we'll get to those
tell us about kind of the last maybe
decade or two of work and what yeah so
when I was a graduate student we had
nine planets actually we've lost one of
those but we had nine we didn't know
whether planets were around other stars
we had no clue and what it took was a
lot of hard work and technology
development in order to be able to
the observational tests that allow us to
infer the presence of a planet because
with very few exceptions we never see
the planet we only see the actions that
it causes on its host star so it was one
week shy of 25 years between the time
that bill Baruch E and Audrey summers
published the first paper on looking for
planets by noticing that if they passed
in front of their star they would block
some of the Starlight almost 25 years
from that paper to the day that the
Kepler spacecraft launched which finally
gave us the ability to stare at hundreds
of thousands of stars simultaneously and
notice if they dimmed if they blinked
and keep track of that and then looked
to see if they did it again and then a
third time with a regular period that
would allow us to infer planets we had
some techniques from the ground that
could see a planet tugging on its star
back and forth but all the dopplers
that's a Doppler shift right but only
for very massive planets it was Kepler
that gave us entree into the realm of
smaller planets and Wow
did that change everything I mean we now
know there are more planets than stars
in this galaxy and we know that they are
in systems with architectures very
different than the solar system that we
inhabit and so now we have a lot of
examples to help us understand this
process of star formation and planet
formation yes 25 years is such a short
period of time and to go from not
knowing any other star systems in terms
of the planets orbiting them to now
knowing what 4000 exoplanet yes yeah
that is crazy interesting that that's a
revolution yeah and it's part of the
revolution we're currently experiencing
the other piece of that is extremophiles
again as a student I was taught that if
he had life in order to have life you
had to have sunlight you had to have
neutral conditions couldn't be very
acidic or basic had to be between
boiling and freezing points of water
couldn't have too much pressure all of
these things that we have now just shown
to be completely incorrect it stems from
our seeing ourselves as the pinnacle of
evolution and of course if you want life
than it has to have conditions that are
conducive for us but we're not we're not
all of life right life is amazing and
occupies all kinds of real estate on
this planet and now we know there's a
lot of potentially habitable real estate
beyond our solar system so it's a
fabulous time to be asking questions
about life beyond this planet yep you in
this means everything from the ocean
floors and what lives there this is on
our planet this this is everything from
the world was it the battery acid yeah
boiling battery has boiling battery as
we go to Yellowstone and you'll find
life in these pools around volcanoes
that are just hugely acidic and very
very hot and such a surprise yeah and
there's these are extremophiles and
there's exoplanets extremophiles these
seem to be yeah two of these most kind
of mind expanding possibilities ya know
who news okay and then that's that's a
that's a massive shift and then that
this is thanks to like you said these
instruments that we developed to be able
to do this so you know kept Kepler went
up and looked at one patch for at the
first mission that was Kepler and then
k2 went and did another a different
mission once a reaction wheel
and but this this uh like you said the
importance of looking at one patch of
sky was that so you could verify the
dimming when the planet would transit in
front of the star then you could see the
dimming and then you would wait maybe a
year or two years or however long
orbital period is ten days and then you
would verify that it did a second time
it did a third time with the dimming and
so this is how to conduct science yes
yes and Bill Farooqi who was the
principal investigator on that mission
was incredibly tenacious he had to
propose that mission multiple times get
turned down and go back and make it
better until it was finally accepted and
he actually made it work on the sky yeah
I'm so grateful that we collected all
that data and now okay so so are there
other really important pieces to to kind
of giving us this cosmic perspective
about the last twenty years yeah
my colleagues and astronomers in general
have a really privileged point of view
right we have a different way of looking
at here and now probably quite different
than you might have been thinking when
you got up this morning but we really
need to rethink what we mean by here and
now in this larger cosmic perspective so
here right here we are if that's where
we are and that's in a building on
Market Street yes and that's in San
Francisco and Google Earth now lets us
be familiar with that and in fact from
the altitude of the low Earth orbit
satellites were on the western part of
the United States and we know that we're
here on earth and this is a selfie of
Earth whoops we've got it so yes this is
since 1968 when Bill Anders took this
photo coming around the limb of the Moon
we'd begun to see ourselves as one body
in the vastness of space yeah and that's
a really amazing perspective because
there all kinds of challenges that we
have on this planet that don't respect
national boundaries that are going to
require us to have this global
enterprise
in order to solve them and it's going to
be really hard to get there if we can't
put ourselves in the right framework and
understand the system this this
wonderful system that we live on this
planet it's a playground for many
whatever they are mm-hmm and do you're
right on the on the human level if we
can't figure out how to be in full
collective harmonious control as well as
balance with the ecosystems that exist
here we're gonna experience some
problems when we before we already have
experienced lots of problems leading up
to this point and I'm very grateful that
we've even made it to here but we got a
lot of work going moving forward so this
is just this is earth rise right and
this gives us the first sort of
perspective of the overview that
overview effect and actually I think
that if more politicians and just people
in general were able to be here
physically I think it would accelerate
us towards that so right actually there
are a number of groups that are trying
to enable that targeting young leaders
whew the future leaders around the globe
trying to give them opportunities to get
up into the stratosphere to actually see
the earth to see that fragile fragile
layer of atmosphere that protects us yes
and have them take that experience
forward as they begin to take their
place and shape the world of the future
yeah I really look forward to all of
those projects and driving the cost down
as well to make it as affordable as
possible for people to go up and and
have their perspective perspective
shifted that way so run go ahead and go
to the next one so again this is a
selfie of Earth this is right below that
tip there's a little dot that's us
that's everything all of us taken to
make the scene it was taken by Cassini
right and we sent out a memo and
suggested you go out on the lawn
and wave hello right is this what's
taken mm-hmm but the next slide I'll
show you pushing back even farther this
is it Voyager four just as it was going
out of the solar system the famous pale
blue dot yeah and then of course we know
now that our Sun is only one of about
400 billion stars in a galaxy that looks
like this now this is not the Milky Way
galaxy nobody got outside the galaxy and
took this picture this is a galaxy that
looks like we think the Milky Way would
look so if we could get out and even
this galaxy we now know is just one of
more than a hundred billion galaxies and
more like 200 billion galaxies in the
observable universe and you see that in
the next slide this is the Hubble Deep
Field where all those little bright dots
are not stars but they are individual
galaxies and until the Hubble Space
Telescope spent hundreds of hours
staring at this tiny patch of sky yes
that was black and blank as far as we
know yes to bring up this universe and
and again our sense of time needs to
expand and to understand that we're in a
particular process of evolution that
began 13.8 billion years ago and that's
kind of a timescale humans don't deal
with very well so if go to the next
slide so we we kind of track our
ourselves I know Emily I know we have so
many slides to go through but I just
want to go back just two slides really
quick because I think it's really
important to make this clear that that
you know this is another one of those
holy-shit moments yes yes yeah yeah
because when you when you when you look
and you just see darkness in the sky and
then you have Hubble look at and that's
an eight-foot mirror in the telescope
so that's absorbing light for how many
street I think it took hundreds of hours
to put this together hundreds of hours
of photographing one patch of sky and
absorbing the light and absorbing the
light and absorbing the light
and then reflecting it onto the it's a
silicon surface that then yeah and then
you look at the photo after that much
exposure time and then you go holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] there's all these galaxies
that we didn't know about and that's and
I mean that's again that's the like Wow
if that's in one patch of sky then
that's an all oh hopefully in a more
everywhere everywhere yeah so and then
that really makes this like how could
one possibly be alone there's so many
other habitable planets so that's
possible we don't know whether or not
it's true it's true cause we gel yeah of
course we're not yeah
stop that and then okay so then on the
next slide as well there's like you were
describing just a sheer timeline
perspective I always like to to really
humble myself by saying that what do you
think I've learned and what do I think
I've learned in 25 years nothing what do
you think a human can learn in a hundred
years
nothing there's just so much knowledge
it's just such I say nothing I think
we've done fabulously well on building
on what this what is that what is this
this is scientific creation myth that's
what it is
we've blooder other cultures have had
creation myths throughout time this is
one that we can have evidence to back up
by looking at the universe with tools
and technologies that we're developing
and improving all the time and it's
pretty it's pretty humbling to
understand that this is really the
context for now yeah you're as though
we're we've built up quite a catalogue
of of scientific of objective truth
based on scientific method and
hypotheses and proving them correct and
then being able to log that and say that
this is what we know then you change it
when we find new evidence that indicates
no we didn't really get that one right
so we need to rethink yeah
put ourselves in this bigger picture so
we can add maybe we can maybe move like
a couple of the grains of sand on the on
the beach of reality as we live our
short hundred year life in this in this
timeline I mean this timeline is just a
link you said it's just you you can't
fathom it we can't even fathom what what
the how society evolved from the
agriculture ten thousand years ago until
now I mean in that yeah so anyway okay
so then you were describing the next
slide well the next slide is sort of the
centuries that humans deal their
families and the next slide talks about
the millennia over which our
architecture and our art and our various
experiments with different types of
legal systems can we move that yeah go
that's the kind of time scale we can
internalize but in fact we have to think
about ourselves going starting much
farther back not just when we branched
off from the Apes but farther back to
2.4 billion years ago when these
blue-green algae
turned our atmosphere rich in oxygen so
that animals were possible yes and then
even fact farther than that this is the
formation of the solar system four and a
half billion years ago we need to go
back farther we need to go back a few
hundred million years before that when
there is this enormous gas cloud which
was had all these waste products from
previous supernovae explosions and if we
go back to that I mean when your kid
asks you where did I come from that's
what you should answer because the
carbon and the calcium in your bones and
they the iron in the hemoglobin in your
blood that was all cooked up in massive
stars billions of years ago that
exploded and then this debris this
beautiful supernova debris then we
condensed into the generation of stars
that would be our son and our
planets and so you are literally as Carl
Sagan told us you're literally made of
Stardust so we have an intimate
connection with this universe that we
think is so large we really are are part
of it all of us and it's what makes it
logical to think that something else
someone else some other kind of life
also evolved originated and evolved
elsewhere so I like your energetic
connection to Stardust I think that in
scientific connectionist artist I think
that is so important in terms of for us
to better understand that these borders
that we've kind of created between each
other that that we can sort of bring
them down over time the more that we
realize this and that it also affects
the mind of a child when it's raised
into the world that it's not necessarily
about you know although it is about my
mom and dad that helped bring me into
the world it's also about that your mom
and dad were brought by their mom and
dad their mom and dad their mom and dad
the Apes exactly thank you yeah exactly
and going all the way back to start us
so when I when I give public lectures I
usually give the audience a homework
assignment at the end of the lecture and
I ask them to go and the next time they
get on their personal devices to change
their profiles so that the first thing
their profile on social media says about
them is that they're an Earthling yeah I
think that's a meme that we should try
and propagate yeah that's a good one I
do you like that one yeah an Earthling
just visiting yeah ron has one too it's
just visiting yeah Iran's yeah yeah I do
like Ron's a lot as well so that that
earthling meme we do we talk about the
importance of this cultural information
transfer and kind of how it's even more
so becoming important with exponential
technology now than genetics in terms of
your ability to impact people and
influence people you can influence so
many more people through mimetics than
you can through
having a child okay so maybe maybe
propagating a mean like earthling and
more people the more people you see that
have that written and the more people
that you see having written things like
just visiting
maybe these are these bonding memes that
can bring us together yeah so that same
social media which doesn't have national
boundaries right a lot of it doesn't
have national boundaries associated with
it also fosters this community kind of
feeling at night so I think you know the
young people today have a spectacular
opportunity for making a better planet
tomorrow of course they have to because
we left them such a mess right yeah they
need to clean up our act as well as find
a way towards sustainability for the
longtime and and I think this is um you
know this is a journey that we've been
on for several millennia trying to patch
together this story and a little change
in the future but I think that perhaps
just detecting the existence of some
other technological species because
that's what we have the ability to do
perhaps right now yeah might might help
us to make it through somebody else
managed to figure this out so dammit
maybe we can - yeah there's the there's
both the importance that you're
describing about having the youth carry
a cosmic perspective into the world so
crucial in figuring out how to do that I
was talking to you about driving out
kids to telescopes and you were teaching
me that we might not have to be doing
that that much anymore in the future
because there's telescopes that from
Central Park you can even get rid of the
light pollution and see stars and
planets so that unlocks people's cosmic
perspective and and in general that that
is super helpful for moving forward you
were also mentioning about
you know I was thinking about earthling
I was thinking about the I thinking
about changing you because I've had
photos of earth on my profile pictures I
think that's really important to sort of
selfie and calling it a selfie and then
actually having images of earthling and
then maybe emojis of earth as as the
start of your social profile could
catalyze a lot of a lot of change for
people's perspective to be augmented
there was something else a you said that
I think I thought I did end up
forgetting but well maybe we will loop
back to it let's continue on on the on
the slides well this is a representative
of our journey and the next slide the
question about whether there's anybody
else out there and and we started the
next slide shows we started
understanding more the scope and the
magnitude of the opportunities for a bio
friendly universe in this past couple of
decades so extremophiles living where
you and I couldn't possibly tolerate so
they're very happy and well evolved and
then this idea that there are more
planets than stars new a new fact yeah
that we did not know that spectacular to
have to have a lifetime encompass going
from no knowledge to to this very
fundamental change yeah yeah and so a
lot of astrobiologists are hoping to be
able to have tools that will allow us to
image distant exoplanets and do a
chemical assay of their atmospheres yes
looking for what we call bio signatures
some indication of chemistry in the
atmosphere which requires biology on the
surface of the planet and what chemistry
requires so the techno signature is
different than a biasing that your bio
signature is yes so explain this to us
because techno signature is more so
stuff that SETI is right well so I think
I think of them as
two pieces of the astrobiology umbrella
we're asking about life beyond Earth we
will we will visit bodies in our solar
system with robots or humans and look
for evidence of life there but when we
get beyond our solar system the
distances are so vast that it's going to
be telescopes and remote sensing so if
you looked at our atmosphere you would
be surprised to see the coexistence of
molecular oxygen and methane gas and why
would you be surprised because if you
put those two gases together in the
laboratory they immediately turn into
carbon dioxide and water and that's
happening in the atmosphere all the time
they're going to this equilibrium state
but because those two and ch4 turn into
water water and carbon dioxide and
dioxide that's what they would like to
be in equilibrium but on the surface of
the planet we have such a strong
biological source function we have we
have photosynthesis pumping oxygen into
the atmosphere we have bovine flatulence
you know cow fart and methanogens in the
guts of termites creating methane so
they are constantly replacing the the
gases that turned into carbon dioxide
and water and it happens because of
biology yes right so now what we wonder
is for a different planet around a
different type of star what might be the
chemical signatures of life that we can
say require biology can't can't get
there abiotic ly you have to have some
kind of life Imogen and methane are two
for all for ours for ours and
questionably for other planets around
other types of stars yes other gases
might be better biomarkers I mean really
truthfully we don't have a smoking gun
here yet yeah yeah there's going to be a
lot of context that is
needed and indeed if you looked at the
earth billions of years ago three
billion years ago there was life but you
didn't have oxygen and methane in your
atmosphere yet yeah so what how would we
see the equivalent of a very young earth
yeah so that's what a lot of folks are
trying to understand and then how would
we then image the atmosphere because
we've seen the you know we were talking
about that transit photometry when
you're looking at the planet that's
moving in front of the star and you're
looking at the star for a long period of
time but then in order to actually be
able to see the atmosphere of that
planet there as either like a sunshade
or there's all these different you've
got to block out that really bright star
right because even if it's a dim star
like an M dwarf it is far brighter than
the tiny little planet which is right
close to it so there have to be some
technologies a coronagraph in the
telescope that essentially puts a patch
right up there and tries to get that
bright sunlight and spread it around the
outside of the field so you can maybe
see a dim planet maybe flying a Sun
Shade in orbit in front of your
telescope to block the Sun it's it's
hard this is not an easy job it may be
the hardest one yet is because you had
when when you're blocking the sunlight
you're trying to catch just the teeny
bit of sunlight that's going through the
planets you want to see the light that's
come from the star through the
atmosphere bounced off the planet come
back out through the atmosphere and
thereby acquired some fingerprints there
will be some wavelengths at which there
is no sunlight or starlight because it's
been absorbed by these chemical
constituents of the atmosphere very hard
this is not going to happen tomorrow so
if there's a gap at oxygen then you know
that there was some oxygen in that
atmosphere yes yeah but you wouldn't
necessarily know whether it was produced
by a lit by biology or by
breaking apart water molecule into
hydrogen and oxygen so there there are
false positives there's this whole
question of what really constitutes a
bio signature and it's going to be I
think full of caveats we're going to
have to tease it out we're gonna have to
know something more about the star and
the planet and even their history if we
can to decide whether this oxygen has
been produced by biology or by some
abiotic process and this is bio
signature work and then my world is not
looking for the microbes it's looking
for the mathematicians so we're looking
for love that one who just can't just
play it down for a second the microbe
looking for the microbes is the bio
signatures looking for the
mathematicians is looking for the techno
signatures that's so funny okay so tell
us why you say this well we're looking
for something that mother nature can't
do that requires an engineer to produce
and and they can be there are many
different possibilities historically
we've been looking for radio signals
we've been looking for optical flashes
but indeed you can think about general
astroengineering they might be modifying
their planet with with for example
suppose their planet is orbiting an M
dwarf star and to be close enough to be
warm that planet is probably going to be
tidally locked just like the moon and
the earth the planet will keep one face
towards the star at all times so it has
a bright side and then it has a dark
side well maybe they don't like that
maybe they would like to have some light
on the dark side so maybe they orbit
huge mirrors to take light from the star
on to the dark side first I've heard of
though
you might catch the glint from that
mirror so you put satellites into into
stationary orbit static orbit and then
that reflect that light on to the dark
side of the planet one idea that's one
idea yeah there's lots of other
mega-structure ideas yeah there's lots
of Dyson spheres are interesting where
you put a satellites around the star to
harness the power of the star and bring
it back that's right the poor we could
have something like our geostationary
orbit of satellites and equipment on
steroids that so you might be able to
distinguish as a planet begins a transit
across its star right as it in the
ingress and again at egress beginning in
the end you might be able to see that a
planet isn't quite round it's got some
extension and that could happen if the
planet had rings like Saturn it could
also happen if the planet had an
enormous geostationary full orbit full
of equipment yeah and you could
hopefully eventually distinguish that
from a ring because a ring is going to
be flat and extended in this direction
radially a geostationary belt will be at
the same a fixed radius but might be
extended perpendicular to the plane
that's one thing that's been suggested
we can if if a technology is needs a lot
of energy and it's using nuclear fission
to produce that energy that it's got
fissile waste products and perhaps it
decides to dispose of them by throwing
them into its star you do that in enough
quantity and you actually change the
spectrum of the star and you get an
enrichment of these lengths aside
elements like price.adam IAM and niobium
the adamian maybe it's making its power
by fusion and if it's got orbital fusion
plants that are
possibly leaking tritium tritium sand
interesting ones got 12.6 de half-life
you don't expect to find it anywhere
except in the vicinity of a new
supernova so you can detect tritium just
the way you can detect atomic hydrogen
it has the equivalent atomic line you go
looking for that and find that line and
you scratch your head about how did this
get here
so either some new astrophysics or maybe
somebody's engineering suppose those
Trappist one planets seven planets all
around us tiny M dwarf star and all
closer in than the orbit of mercury
suppose all of those seven planets end
up looking identical
they've all been transformed to be the
same they should have a difference in
their properties as they get farther
from their star but if they're all the
same maybe some engineers made them that
way yeah okay these are the kinds of
things that we're thinking about as well
as looking for the radio signals and the
optical flashes I do have a very
interesting feeling that by the end of
my lifetime that I think will have had
the instruments go up into space that
enable us to photograph some of these
megastructures ooh thank you Ron come on
fifteen minute I'm Rob I have a really
good feeling about that for some reason
I think I'm envisioning us propagating a
photo around the planet that shows a
photograph of all those star system only
a couple dozen light-years away that
we've identified a next an exoplanet
that looks like it has these
megastructures and that like really
looks real and we're now then we go and
we aim more of our instruments there and
start trying to figure it out so maybe
I'm a hopeless romantic but but I also
think that that is very possible and
it's exciting and the way that you speak
about techno signatures in their fullest
extent
you know a lot of the work that you're
doing right now at SETI is very
interesting because we are listening and
we're also propagating as well signal
all the time in all these different
directions and so people listening to us
can find this quite easily because if
they're close because that bubble of
radio transmission is only about a
hundred light-years from us right we
haven't been doing this for a long time
in terms of cosmic times Oh duh yeah
that's right that's totally right yeah
yeah they have to be within 100 years
light-years within us because the radio
waves have only been going out for a
hundred years oh that's such that bad
bad that makes it so much more
understandable why right here you were
talking about this this century and I
think I really agree with you so in 2004
craig Venter and Daniel Cohen wrote this
paper where they said that the 20th
century had been the century of physics
and all of these fantastic general and
special relativity and the less standard
model and all of this but they said the
21st century was going to be the century
of biology and of course they were
talking about genomics and proteomics
and and that's played out so much more
rapidly I think than even they could
have pretty yes but I think that the
real ly correct prophecy is that the
21st century is the century of biology
on earth and beyond beyond yeah exactly
that's what's gonna be happening and I'm
sorry you're around to see the end of
the century
maybe sure you will you'll just be in
another dimension come on these are just
machines yes well but it is actually
interesting that for us to to detect
someone else's technology that
technology has to be long-lived because
if in fact technologies arise
and they get turned off or they do
themselves in on times that are short
small we compared to a cosmic times then
when we're not going to be close enough
to them in space and then overlapping in
time during the 10 billion year history
of our galaxy yes yes longevity is
really really really important yeah but
that also means that if we ever succeed
we learned something phenomenal which is
that it's possible to stay around for a
long yeah yeah which a lot of possible
think that that's one of the reasons why
the Fermi paradox exists is because it's
very tough for these thinking creatures
to figure out how to work together on
these rocks orbiting stars yeah but if
we ever succeed we understand that
technology can be stabilizing and can
provide a long future and that's why
Phil Marcin had this lovely phrase he
would call SETI the archeology of our
future archaeology because at the speed
of light if the message is coming from
very large distances it's going to be
telling us about their past but if we
succeed if we find a message it really
means that we can have a long future
because technology has been able to
stabilize at least one other at least
one has a place in that and that's this
it's like the Earth's boom belt I guess
is this hundred years sort of where the
radio waves are right now and that sort
of it's being expanded all the time but
then also it makes us of course wonder
then how far away then the other
civilizations would you know wouldn't
need to to be in order for us to be
receiving what they're propagating so
I'm really happy that we have all of the
all of the push with SETI there seem to
be so many different divisions can we
see if we can like get them straight we
I mean besides like besides NASA and
then you know SpaceX and Blue Origin and
bow wings doing some space stuff and
then you have like the Chinese National
Space Administration European Space
Administration right so we have agency
so we have you know these different arms
around the world and then then there is
you know the SETI is searching for
extrastriate elegance and then you have
you know NASA's is contracting a lot of
the the satellite there are the
satellites that are like the gene flow
Space Telescope and so it's you know
continues yeah there is so much to
understand there is so much to try and
learn and different modalities of
getting that information so it's a huge
continuum and it's all good yes we had a
Korean Leavitt who stole yes yeah we we
just had a crayon on this week actually
and he was he was teaching us about
imaging the earth through small
satellites and you know these massive
constellations small satellites and how
fascinating those are as well these
little bread loaves that are orbiting
yeah and then I mean we have we have so
much more to unpack and talk about this
is all good the cosmic perspective is
very important for the longevity of
civilization and also working together
and being kind to the sisters and the
brothers on the planet that are that are
everybody now we do ask these questions
on our show and I think that you'll have
especially interesting answers to them
so we ask our guests if they think that
there were alone in the cosmos I don't
know the answer to that that I'm working
very hard to try and find out so it's
literally if I told you an answer it
would be religion yeah I don't know the
answer but it's after millennia of
asking the priests and the philosophers
what we should believe we've now gotten
to the point where engineers and
scientists can do experiments make
observations to try and find out what
the answer is and boy I'm on board for
that yeah well Joe I just told you the
answer a little while ago and it isn't
religion
you don't for a minute think that it is
you might want you to think it's God but
it certainly isn't just as it's trying
to figure out life itself show me the
evidence yeah I just wish we could right
here
yeah I know I know right here I know but
it's stuck in you which is so difficult
for the scientists and if you cut me
open
it'll be silicone and wires and stuff
like that yeah I didn't want to do that
and make a big mess right we're were
there other do we have other slides
Ronnie there are lots of others there
are lots of other ones yeah where were
there other ones that came to mind that
are would be a portkey cycle through
them quick yeah I had so these are
optical and in the previous where radio
telescopes and now the next one is we're
starting to work in the infrared and
keep going and this is the kind of thing
we're looking for patterns that are
clearly engineered and not natural and
yet there's a difference between the
what is a natural pattern of versus a
right an engineered one yeah and so
basically there's noise and then there's
not noise yes and that not noise is not
something that nature can produce the
next slide is is just talking about the
longevity issue and if planets
technologies come in and fade out in
short timescales we'll never succeed
with this sort of search the next slide
is film arson and the archeology of our
future we did that he owes me money too
and we've done a lot of searching we've
worked pretty hard but if you take the
multi-dimensional space in which is
signal not not engineered planet pushing
around or as all of that meta structures
but just signals that huge volume of
space different parameters that a signal
could have that you have to explore and
you said that volume is equal to the
volume of the Earth's oceans then since
we started we've looked at one glass of
water
and you know that's discouraging in some
sense but on the other hand we're now
riding an exponential yes so our systems
are getting better
increasing bouncing tubs and then soon
we'll be using have boats full so it's
too soon just decide there no fish in
the ocean this is a telescope in
Northern California that we've built to
do SETI and radio astronomy the Allen
telescope array and another beautiful
picture of it and this is our coverage
of the sky so many red dwarfs well red
dots there are solar-type stars in there
as well but and then this is a yuri
milner is as for the past two years
gotten into the game you're a funding
breakthrough listen a hundred million
dollar pledge for ten years and so
they're working at Green Bank West
Virginia at parks this is the automatic
planet finder at lick and then soon the
new large telescope in China yes and
then this is a meerkat and Square
Kilometre Array and there are other
projects going on around the globe at
different frequencies and even a lot of
data mining spacecraft data looking for
those mega structures looking for the
infrared heat radiation from the back of
a Dyson Sphere and here's a project that
we are starting that will look at all
the sky all the time for bright optical
flashes because some of these signals
may be transient and if you're not
looking everywhere correct you'll miss
them listen so this is a laser SETI
project from the SETI Institute so if
you have these hubs around the planet
and they're all looking out all the time
what what is the laser flash that you
are looking for what would that be it
could be a deliberate signal or it could
be one of these enormous accelerators
like star shot is talking about building
a big phased array of laser begins to
accelerate a sail
an interstellar sale and it might come
across our line of sight it's incredibly
bright yeah it will only be for a very
short period of time yeah yeah and then
we look forward to though the large
Space Telescope's so excited for these
yeah so space so I go fingers crossed if
that one goes in the drink
it will be huge devastating for so many
people and then also tests is up now
Tesla's up now transiting exoplanet
survey survey yeah and then this is a
weird telescope that's been suggested
not yet built this is looking at pole
sky right yes is looking at the whole
sky like the nearest nearest stars and
exoplanets are anyway that hopefully
will be found in in a timely way that
James Webb can follow up on I can follow
up on it and then how BIG's the mirror
on tests they're very small they're for
small telescopes okay okay cool so it's
nearby bright stuff yeah okay that that
telescope that we just saw the one that
was just prior to this one Ron yes yeah
this is a very strange hybrid looks
that's kind of like a hybrid between a
radio interferometer yeah an optical
telescope it would have one purpose and
that's trying to make an opacity map of
Proxima B yeah because that's dar and
it's planet are so close relative to
every other system that you build a
single purpose telescope from the ground
and try and collect light curve after
light curve after like her and then
invert them to give you an opacity map
that might show you the differences
between continents and oceans might in
fact show you bio signatures and even
techno signatures so interesting and
then yes so this is trying to hit this
can be a ground optical and radio
telescope that can then be used for just
whatever is four and a quarter
light-years away what's the next solar
system out there's a eight but you're
yeah that's something like something
okay cool so it could be used for that
afterward as well potentially it won't
work as well right it's taking advantage
of the fact that the Proxima system is
so closed so people will certainly be
used on the others what the its ability
to find small planets and image them
will be compromised could probably find
giant planets and these are some of the
other pieces of large glass that are and
and radio telescopes they're coming on
the air in the future this is what you
were talking about in terms of the
towards the end of the century being
able to have capabilities that might
actually succeed in finding bio
signatures and imaging exoplanets or
finding techno music cited this is so
exciting I love seeing projects like
this and we're gonna inspire the next
generations to keep going with this look
at ourselves in the mirror that's right
I think this whole business of SETI is
showing us ourselves in a mirror and
this should have been animated with lots
of different different looking
individuals but the message is that
compared to something else out there
we're all the same so we can use this
concept in this project to trivialize
the differences along here
yeah and of course this is on a finite
world a cosmic perspective isn't a
luxury it's a necessity yeah I quoted
this dis and posted it across so cuz I
loved it so much it's a really good one
yeah Caleb Scharf at Columbia University
very very wise gentleman this is not a
luxury anymore this is a necessity and
it also means that for all the the kids
and the parents that are running around
hectic every single day unable to get a
cosmic perspective it's really important
for us to figure out how to create a
social fabric that enables people to
spend time looking at the Stars and
contemplating the cosmos and expanding
their mind to this awareness looking at
ourselves objectively in the mirror like
you said shouldn't take a waiting to
find a civilization outside of ours to
realize we're all one Jill do you think
that
we're in a simulation I'm not I am NOT a
fan of that but I can't disprove it
right I sometimes think about the errors
that propagate with biological
reproduction as being something that
might put put that simulation idea to to
rest but I think that then even a bigger
computer could simulate even those
errors and how evolution proceeds have
you used virtual reality yet yeah you
have yeah interesting because that and
you understand obviously exponential
technology and growth rates because if
you know the same way that the
instruments that we used to map the
cosmos are going to be used to you know
throw us in right here
if you can't distinguish between
realities you just forget that you're in
the virtual world and that could be what
this is yeah I do that until I stub my
toe because I'm not looking and then
well that's what I'm saying and then the
haptics kick in and then you stub your
you stub your toe and you you know
that's what you feel now but you're
really wearing it the full immersive
experience outside of this right so
anyway it's it's it's a great I think
thought experiment I'm happy that you
have a unanswered what Jill last
question is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world I think a
dark sky and a quiet metal looking up
it's just so incredibly beautiful I
agree with you yeah and is that you
impact that a bit more is that the kind
of possibility
oh no it's because it's it's
breathtaking it just makes me stop and
then expand and reach out to be part of
that it's just yes yes yes I found out
you know and a dark if you're really in
a dark site the sky
is so amazingly full of stars and it's
yeah yeah favorite thing yeah we're
talking like going really far away from
light pollution and looking up at
pitch-black night no moon even and you
can really get lost really get lost and
you that that's when you got the
billions of stars actually hitting the
light is hitting your eyes from the
billions of stars and yeah it is yeah I
agreed that why has it been so long
since I've done that we need to do that
more often and just in general you need
to get kids doing that more often Jill
thank you so much for coming on the show
and teaching us more about the cosmic
perspective in such as much nuance as we
could unpack in such a short episode we
got some cool events like women and
Technology events that would love to
injured host you at and bring you to
those and yeah and also just continue
inspiring in the next generations of
thinkers and doers in space and
especially this millennial and Gen Z
generation yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
you earthling earthling throw the earth
emojis in your social profiles that's a
good take away from today make sure we
all go do that thanks everyone for
tuning if you guys had a good time
go share with a couple people start
talking them more about the cosmic
perspective and about all the nuance of
finding life and also understanding life
then go and create with this content
don't just consume it so don't just
watch this but go and write about it go
and read about it go and make videos
about it go and create with it's their
businesses with it also subscribe
comment below let us know your thoughts
thanks everybody for tuning in Thank You
Jill thank you for having me and good
luck with simulation thank you very much
we're gonna be filled sports stadium
soon and you're gonna be part of this
Ron thank you so much producing and
directing much love everybody peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]